titeuf là beaucoup trop d'imagination il
est hyper frimeur ils pensent qu'aux
filles
il est pas travailleur mais quand ils
travaillent c'est en trichant sur piste
mouillée france qu'au sexe est bon alors
si je résume titeuf c'est qu'un frimeur
un tricheur un cancre en plus ils
inventent n'importe quoi et c'est un
obsédé du zizi sexuel
d'où lui viennent ses merveilleuses
qualités pour le savoir nous sommes
allés chez lui en suisse pour voir si
par hasard son caractère ne lui vient
pas de zep sont apa dessinateur c'est
surtout la co je m'assieds pour faire
mes bandes dessinées où je suis
tranquille donc la paix puis je peux
faire un peu mon petit coeur pendant que
zep était au travail nous en avons
profité pour demander à hélène sa femme
si tout d'abord comme titeuf
il ne serait pas un peu fraîcheur il a
dû tricher dans son enfant fumée
et dans la vie aujourd'hui tel que je le
connais je n'ai jamais vu tricher et
manu pas six mois est un feuilleton fil
23 crouch qui bouge avec explosion en
dessin est riche rappaz il décale cra
jamin titeuf
il leur dessinera vers travaille
d'ailleurs 15 heures par jour et quand
il était petit contrairement à tielt off
il était très bon en classe c'est sans
doute comme cela qu'il est devenu une
vraie star de la bd avec son dernier
album mais ça ne les empêche pas comme
titeuf d'être un peu timide tu ne me
présente pas tes petits camarades qui
ferait rougir titeuf ça peut faire
confiance est par exemple si on le filme
alors qu'il achète du papier toilette
il peut pas laisser doit l'acheter il
prend sur lui il souffla y pose de
papier et après ils le cachent dans un
sac
vp donc timide mais ça ne m'empêche pas
d'être comme son héros légèrement obsédé
du zizi sexuel
ça vous dirait jamais ce qui m'arrive de
mes gars qui est ce que tu peux te
retrouver tous du but
si on fait des blagues du heavy ça le
fait toujours vraiment rire suffit que
quelqu'un contre août ou roth sans faire
exprès alors là n'empêche c'est pas
parce qu'il est obsédé du physique il
n'est jamais sérieux cette année par
exemple mais pas participer à une
campagne pour aider les enfants victimes
de la guerre
une campagne contre les mines
antipersonnel d'handicap international
qui montre que zep a aussi un côté
révolter
si déteste l'injustice il a horreur
qu'on soit injuste avec les enfants et
il a envie de lutter contre ça en bref
chez eux il n'y a pas que le côté gamin
il y a aussi un côté adultes et même un
côté généreux ce qui n'est pas toujours
le cas de titeuf
ça fait drôlement plaisir et deux
petits-enfants pauvre tu sais il faut
savoir partager dans la vie et trois
syriens de kidnapping wade avant et toi
tu n'es qu'un vilain petit garçon
égoïste